the hostility of these people in
countries around the world is out of all
proportion to that to any other kind of
group I can think of I want to show you
one other thing since we've done dougas
Murray and we've done Jordan Peterson
how about I give you the trifecta of
Sanity uh this is a video of Thomas Soul
this is from probably 20 25 years ago uh
Thomas Soul being asked about why
anti-Semitism is so prevalent in history
you have u a chapter that's the first
chapter is black rednecks and white
liberals the second chapter is are Jews
generic MH why the jump to from black
rednecks and white liberals to our Jews
generic what's the point well this book
is a really about ethnic and cultural
issues in general so there's a chapter
on the Jews a chapter on the Germans and
then there's a chapter on history in
general so that that's uh they they're
lumped together because they're all
cultural ethnic issues fascinating story
because among the the the middleman
minorities of which the Jews are most
prominent uh the hostility of these
people in countries around the world is
out of all proportion to that to any
other kind of group I can think of uh in
terms of the violence uh the vi the
number of uh of BL the number of Chinese
killed let's say in one year uh and by
mob action exceeds all the blacks
lynched in the entire history of the
United States and the number of
Armenians killed in in Turkey you know
during the first world war is greater
than that and of course the number of
Jews slaughtered on a number of
occasions in history even before the
Holocaust is greater than that so that
the question is why particular kind of
people are the targets of so much us
venomous hatred and I think the answer
is that um they not they not only
succeed they succeed in a way which is a
threat to the egos of other people but
the guy who comes here let's say from
Vietnam or Korea and arrives here with
little more than the clothes in his back
and a few broken words of broken English
uh and a decade later he has his own
little business and you see his son few
years after that getting ready to go off
to Har MIT you got to ask yourself you
either got to you know you you you
you've got to hate yourself for saying
my God I I'm been stagnating this guy
was nothing and now he's weing up or
you're going to have to hate him years
ago one official of one of the Jewish
organizations in New York asked me what
what can Jews themselves do uh in order
to minimize the hostility they face I
gave him a one- word answer
fail because as long as you succeed
you're going to be
hated I personally would rather succeed
and be hated than fail and be loved and
that probably is the story of the Jews
the interesting thing with Israel
related to all this is you have Jews who
are not only succeeding uh you know
they're they're struggling over this
last month obviously but you can there
is a sense I was talking to an Israeli
friend last night uh there is a sense in
the country that they are going to be
stronger than ever on the other side of
this that this is ironically bringing
them together it's it's sort of baked in
the code it's what every Jewish holiday
is about oh they killed a whole bunch of
us uh they didn't kill all of us still
here let's eat and Jews still are here
that is why they particularly hate
Israel because it's a place where not
only Jews are succeeding uh but then
Jews refuse to fail and they've got
weapons to make sure that that doesn't
happen